[Musique]
ça fait une demi heure que je t'attends
tu es d'oublier hiver soit je vais être
en retard des produits elle a beau être
le plus petit la grippe a
le père de a fini sa sieste il est
complètement ouf compères font comme ça
il est juste de signer aux espèces et
aux tuteurs d'arsenal ylvanie à te voir
c'est une chance unique pour toi ça peut
changer ta vie et culture
maintenant qui t'a vu jouer trouve que
tu es trop petit un jour elle monta
creed et sémantique au [ __ ] t'as fait
ça
j'aimerais bien qu'on partage sur le
monde fr alors il va d'abord falloir
vous occuper de vous vous sentez capable
open moi tu parlais pas passer par
footballeur que tu viens c'est barman
palais sur mer
[Musique]
bonjour pastis billard à cazaux du
shérif non ça marchait par semaine pour
le coach mon avenir ici qu'à passer du
temps ensemble
il a fait ça pour son père pour le
sortir de son trou
n'état pas t'occuper d'éviter pas
responsable de tout et cette fois-ci
vous allez vous battre ce gars maillard
tellement merveilleuse année voilà je
suis raide
la fourmi ya pas un sec 14/100 du
collectif
tout pour la survie de l'équipe
eva commandant chambre
c'est un discours ne peut pas citer